l'aimant tellement d'un réseau de
pédophilie sur internet dans toute
l'europe plusieurs dizaines de personnes
interpellées dans 7 pays pour toutes
nouvelles images d'enfants violés mise
sur le réseau et les membres d'un site
internet gagner des étoiles et la
possibilité d'aller encore plus loin
dans l'ignoble comme un jeu il faut le
lire pour le croire
dans le rapport établi par les
enquêteurs des centaines milliers
d'imagés de vidéos saisies il y aurait
bien un moyen d'empêcher la
prolifération ces sites dont les
utilisateurs payent les services le plus
souvent avec des cartes de crédit mais
pour l'instant et bien les sociétés en
question ne veulent pas perdre des
marchés qui se révèle très lucratif
mathias hillion blaze vanille enfants de
3 à 10 ans bb tortures viols la liste
sordide des photos disponibles sur ce
site n'en finit plus sur internet la
pédophilie est un marché les images
d'enfants abusés des produits est un
supermarché une activité criminelle qui
est là en toute impunité
je crois qu'on peut craindre que
désormais nous sommes nous soyons
rentrer dans une l'égalité de fait
puisque on peut se procurer aussi bien
des photos montrant des enfants violés
par des adultes que des vidéos sur
chaque site quelques photos sont en
accès libre pour voir les autres il faut
sortir sa carte bleue et comme pour
n'importe quel achat en ligne
le paiement est sécurisé et protégé le
numéro de la carte bancaire ne servira
qu une fois des sociétés américaines
dominent ce marché lucratif mais ne sont
pas très regardante sur le contenu des
pages qu'elle sécurisé mais c'est quand
même incroyable que au sein de votre
société y est pas des gens qui soit
chargée de regarder les sites avec
lesquels vous travaillez visiblement
certaines sociétés se pose pas trop de
questions visiblement certains société
ne se pose pas de question je dirai même
que certaines sociétés profitent de ça
et non
ray des marchés que pour ce genre de
situation et que pour assister ce genre
de sites
autrement dit s'il n'y avait pas de
société pour sécuriser les transactions
les sites pédophiles seraient moins
nombreux mais personne n'a jamais songé
à responsabiliser les professionnels du
paiement en ligne
jusqu'à présent la loi du marché est la
plus forte